- The time on the bottom is critical.
It's our bread and butter so to speak
so we use every second.
The Alvin is the United States
deepest diving manned submersible.
We're capable of going to 4500 meters.
At one time in the past, the
lunches were a bit varied.
There was a particular
lunch that caused some
gastronomical distress and
they had to abort the dive.
We do all these amazing
things but the people
that make the food onboard
the ship, they're heroes.
They really are.
They put a lot of thought
into it and they keep people
really happy in port.
- Morning begins with the
making of the Alvin lunch.
We keep peanut butter and honey mixed up.
This is the favorite combination
and the one that pleases everybody.
Everybody's got a favorite jam but it,
it's not the same as the next guy.
You're not going down
there to dine in splendor.
You need fuel food.
This is what we will provide.
Something real nutritious.
We will provide wheat bread.
It's the best, most wholesome choice.
After which it goes in lunch.
We seal it up, place it in the bag.
Thermos of cold water.
Thermos of hot coffee.
- I love peanut butter honey.
(upbeat happy music)
Pretty good.
See how the honey gets all crystallized?
But clearly we have to ask whether people
are allergic to peanut butter.
That would be bad.
(laughter)
(quiet music)
It would be impossible for
humans to visit the deep ocean
without a machine like Alvin.
If we don't stop for lunch,
typically what will happen
is you get a breather
from the work, you reach
back, you grab your lunch.
You grab a sandwich and
you're looking out the window
flying the sub, take a bite
of your sandwich, stash it.
I've had close to 350
dives in the submarine
all over the world's oceans
in various different places and depths.
And seen almost
indescribably amazing places.
I would wager that anybody who's eaten
a peanut butter honey sandwich in Alvin,
every time they eat one,
thinks about their dive.